it's certainly not the weather which
draws so many migrants to Britain the
attraction is altogether something else
new opportunities and a better standard
of living but the sense that British
people are somehow losing out to those
who come to live and work here has
become so pervasive immigration is
threatening to destroy Britain's
membership of the EU this is the South
Coast seaside town of Bournemouth it
thrives on tourism as things stand
anyone from Europe can live and work in
the UK at the Cumberland Hotel perched
on the cliff top the majority of the
staff on non British EU citizens
breakfast time and in truth amongst
these holiday makers it's hard to find a
voice which isn't voting out come
referendum day in this hotel you know
where you're staying on a nice holiday
80 percent of the workforce are non
British but from within the EU so so why
does it bother you about the fact that
people are coming here if you say well
let you know that they're serving you
breakfast they're very nice what was the
problem about oh you trying to get an
appointment to the doctors you go in
hospital you that dentist
we just got too many people we can't
cope I mean it's got to come a time when
you pull the shutters now and say that's
it
I saw in a nutshell that's the kind of
view David Cameron is up against if he's
going to keep Britain in Europe you
might call Margaret Kubek a sort of a
model you migrant we enjoy breakfast
ladies everything's all right
polish hard-working she came to britain
when the shutters came up in 2004 and
Poland joined the EU she's now got two
children and citizenship but she admits
she knows people who've come to milk the
system the lifes they're not my part of
life's life to go in and get the
benefits from somewhere else so do you
know people do you know people that take
advantage of the British system yes you
know lots of Polish people Portuguese
Italian some people work here and then
they come here to work just a few hours
to get the benefits yes like I said I've
agree with this like top-up benefit like
a top-up if Britain votes to get out of
Europe EU citizens already working here
can stay but after that there's
confusion vote leave want an Australian
style points system open to everyone if
you want out you really want out Kevin
wood runs the Cumberland with his work
hat on he fears the recruitment headache
I am going to vote to Romania but I do
understand brexit I just wish the
succession of the UK government's had
dealt with it better in the past because
I don't think we'd be at this stage
right now because so many people out
there have very angry very angry I mean
some of my own family are angry some of
my friends are angry but I'm looking at
a bigger bit about immigration here yeah
yeah you used to work with selma i did
yes yeah and then how do you know the
others i met them on the neck when was
waiting to go on a coach trips and we
just got talking this group of friends
are on a coach trip from newark in
Nottinghamshire and pretty fired up
about immigration do it is actually
while its warned with Polish people the
government promised and failed to reduce
net migration to the UK to the tens of
thousands this group all seemed to have
anecdotes of how they perceive British
people have suffered because of Europe's
open borders we were stood in the post
office one day and there was an old lady
in front of us and two Polish lads the
girlfriends or the the wise was strudle
well away and this lady when talked got
two more now come back she says into the
inter to pity she says I've worked all
my life in this country and I get 60
pound a week they go come into the
country straight on the dole and what do
they get 90 pound a week in benefit in
benefits the government says it's
changed the rules there's no more
something for nothing that's what David
Cameron says the government tells lies
you just don't believe you don't believe
I don't know and is that entirely why
you're going to vote out at the
referendum because of immigration yes do
you feel that the character of Britain
has changed I do yeah now what I want
where it does spinning
you've got the triangle in the point at
the doctor's he can't wait at least two
or three weeks ago in Fineman and now
we're used to go in and you're Mecca
moment you go you have to sign in now as
you know we've got about 10 different
flags there to say what nationality you
are before you do you know anybody who's
gonna vote to stay in the EU no
so we decided to introduce Pauline Hague
and Jan and John Emerson to some new
friends who want Britain to remain in
Europe taking them on an open-top bus
tour to discuss their views
this is Iver and Doreen's slapper from
Middlesex also enjoying a mini break in
Bournemouth well unfortunately for John
and in woody the thinks like him it's
not that simple as the former senior
manager in the clothes industry either
believes migrant workers have a lot to
offer and coming out of Europe isn't a
solution to immigration concerns some
will come course and some will go in the
meantime the ones that say we'll do what
everybody does they'll work they'll be
and all the things that everybody's
already heard about hospitals they're
all no intention of working you know
why'd you say they're living there I I
had supposed to been to polish loves
living next door to me for a year there
was in rental accommodation I own mine I
had to go to sleep at a friend's house
because I couldn't stop in me own hours
because of the noise I mean there but 19
on him in that room you don't even go
around to complain to them because they
say I'm racist but I'm not it was the
noise and that their sling that out yet
all the time you raised it I'm not I
want I'm not and they should not be
allowed to come into this country
anybody I don't care who it is until
they've got a job my English teenagers
that make a noise when they have parties
what do you see is the benefits of
remaining within the I feel like it's
part of a family I love Europe I want to
be part of it and I think I don't want
to be insular and I just think it would
look bad and we were we wouldn't it
wouldn't give a good impression to the
rest of Europe if we come out
the vast majority of the economic think
tanks believe that this country will be
far better off staying within the Union
do you not listen to what they say do
you care about what we're going through
sand banks at the minute which is where
a lot of the rich and famous these big
wealthy houses do you think this
referendum is a caste divide that
wealthier people are going to vote to
remain and that working-class people are
going to vote to get out of Europe I
think southerners vote to stop in
northerners or say come out because it's
class distinction I think in spand banks
where land values are the fourth highest
in the world we put that theory to the
test
dropping into the landmark Haven hotel
to meet property developer Richard Carr
it would be very easy for me to vote to
remain and I'm not a little Englander in
any way whatsoever what we shouldn't be
doing is just locking ourselves down to
taking our staff or taking our future
employees from the European Union we
live in a global world now and
unfortunately the European Union might
have five hundred million people in it
but there's a wall around it and we need
to trade outside of those five hundred
million people
it's coffee time at the marina in
sandbanks I'm alone watching this group
yes Bruce wants to stay in Europe and
still believes EU immigration can be
tackled from within could control it we
would have done by now wouldn't we I
think we've seen with negotiations that
we can not control the number of people
who come to Brittany for me well yes but
I think that we could do we've got to be
able to change the mindset of the of the
European community from sandbanks just 7
miles that the coast is Boscombe it's in
the bottom 10% most deprived areas in
England this square struggles with
antisocial behavior and you can't say
it's all down to EU migrants but there
is an underlying tension randhir so
absolute dies to bring kids off this
area the other day those piles of
rubbish everywhere in here and that was
the Romanian lot because we were in the
park watching him
they just don't pick up after their cell
do you think that there is tension in
this area with people from within EU
what I've seen yeah it's quite a lot
actually
all right you always get it adults
fighting over here by different like
English paleis Agra is from poland and
so those relations can sometimes feel
awkward especially when people from the
EU get accused by Brits of taking all
the jobs people on benefits who are in
the program saying or because all the
Polish people are coming and taking our
jobs but I don't think that's true
because you know we do find a job but
because there is a job and we take
everything you know what I mean and you
know I work nights probably why do you
think they say that then if I think they
just lazy to cordon above it you know
because it's for the British people yes
the British which are on on benefit a
gas tax shelves in a supermarket why the
work and you know don't have little top
up but not much so you know you claim
some benefits and yes
yes just the child tax credits yeah
this Bournemouth estate was built in the
last couple of years - he's a chronic
housing shortage Kelly Ward lives here
with her two children like a lot of
people on the estate she hasn't
registered for the referendum but says
she would vote to leave the EU because
she believes Brits are losing out to
people who've come from other parts of
Europe obviously post papers a lot of
days and you know like I say they take
our jobs and things here and that and I
thinks I'm fair
that we should you know someone next
door where it shouldn't be like a job
because of myself because if you tried
to get a job and found that it's gone to
someone else for me then you know I
haven't actually no not the moment but I
expect I will I would definitely vote
out some people say though that the
migrants who come from within Europe are
doing the jobs that British people don't
want to do well that's rubbish in there
that's rubbish you know do you know
anybody that's got a job that did the
job because my company alone Romanians
and well only one of them of account as
a decent worker and can barely speak the
world of English there's two of them
that are okay but are you saying that
you know British people that would like
those jobs but can't get the thing is
they don't pay the money our company
really to get the British people to work
there so I suppose it's difficult in
that way
that's sense the frustration that some
migrants don't speak English is a
recurring complaint yeah
Clark Hartley is voting in not everyone
shares the feeling that Britain is
losing its way of life we're very very
closed door in this country and I think
maybe in a case where to play store in
which we find these cultures come in as
a problem and I don't think they are I
think we're creating the problem but
it's the numbers I think do need to stop
the best bit about being a citizen of
Europe may simply be the ability for all
of us to take off and earn as we travel
Xavier and Sergio from Spain on living
the dream to travel it's the most
amazing thing because you discover
yourself and at the same time you meet
new people new life mmm I think it's the
best way to enjoy what life is you'll be
lost without us in Europe with you I
don't think so I think
England would be lost without Europe in
the end this referendum could just come
down to heart first his head the notion
true or not but as part of Europe towns
like Bournemouth may not feel like
forever England